welcome to episode 3 of podly the
official peacemaker companion podcast
brought to you by hbo max and dc
the plot thickens and so does peacemaker
as him and vigilante have a cheeky
menage
so we'll get into that but first we will
have an amazing interview with danielle
brooks who plays adebayo in peacemaker
so we've got a bunch of questions for
her we're going to chat it vibin and
just asking her a few
cheeky cheeky little questions so let's
get into it
why is there a bald eagle in your car
that's equal eagerly is your pet eagle
yeah
is your dog named doggy
all right do you have a daughter named
daughtery
hey how's it going i'm iffy waddy way
and i'm fiona nova and this is podly the
official peacemaker companion podcast
from hbo max and dc and we're gonna get
into some super fun stuff this is the
third episode we've been doing this
three episodes now but just once more
this is a companion podcast this is
episode 3 companion podcast episode 3 of
the peacemaker show if you have not
watched episode 3 yet hit pause go back
watch it and then come back to us after
you're done watching it because spoilers
for episode 3 ahoy we're about to go all
in well okay yeah so we jump into every
they're prepping for this i guess
excursion they're about to go to where
they're gonna check out this senator
goff yeah senator goff
and so
where they're all chatting and then uh
the best part about this scene is when
vigilante is hiding behind the dumpster
yeah but everyone can see him yeah he's
he's trying his best to to spy on them
but just
doing a horrible job and when he gets
caught just is
yeah it's just trying to figure
everything out and he just does not take
that helmet off it's really gross no i
think it's good it adds to his charm we
love to see it and then also something
of note peacemaker being left-handed
which is not shocking why does that not
shock me i don't know something about
him looks like he's could be a
left-handed person i don't know you know
when you see somebody
you possibly yeah the left-handed energy
you pop you probably are left-handed i
don't know why
but something about it yeah something
about it
the energies yeah yeah i just said lives
like what i don't
[Music]
yeah yeah but so yeah so we're gonna
check out senator goff who possibly the
entire family
are butterflies so they're gonna check
it out they're gonna scope it out up
until this moment we had no clue what
butterflies are
and then we um and then we this is where
we finally get answers but i think the
first clue is we
see them
put like weird
weird
of some kind yeah yeah but i think um
especially in this episode we really get
to see that uh peacemaker
is you know it possibly is a peacemaker
and doesn't really want to like kill the
kid yeah kids there's multiple kids yeah
and so he's kind of hesitant on that um
and he doesn't really want to so he he
actually really badly draws the dove
yeah yeah on the on the side of the yeah
yeah yeah because remember you need yeah
he needs the dove of peace to be able to
use
yeah
yeah even with that even with the dove
of peace he wasn't able to kill the kids
but you know who was able to kill kids
vigilante yeah he he got about it
without a hesitation he just just
just went ham yeah he went him and it
was in the most caring and thoughtful
way yeah the peacemaker was like hey man
don't worry
i got this yeah take a break yeah you
just uh
just you don't want snacks you want
snacks you want water yeah just just let
me kill them
vigilante always being so caring and
being so great yeah i mean yeah i i
think
again this is this is opening us up to
peacemaker's
personality his beliefs his his vows
essentially just like understanding what
kind of a guy he is i mean does he care
does he care to kill people no but at
least he has a soft spot for kids yeah
which most people should have i think
yeah
but yeah and then um you know after all
the killing does start we get to meet uh
judo master which we do yeah we do yeah
we do meet him we see we see him yeah we
see him with the bodyguard yeah and he's
eating the chicken and he's eating the
cheetos he's with the bodyguard and we
do get a little glimpse where they say
like hey he's like
he's like a martial arts pro well also
we get a glimpse of him eating the chips
and he's like can i have someone's like
no he's like well i'll need the cards
anyway and he's like clearly yeah
clearly
so sassy and the way he was walking was
very sassy too yeah um yeah he was like
what a weird i think
i think just like
james gunn adding these characters that
i know i would have never heard of yeah
am i just someone who again hasn't
really gone into the comic books and
doesn't really like know the world like
you do
i would have never heard of a judo
master yeah or like any of those kinds
of characters but it's just so funny to
see how how james gunn portrays them
yeah oh 100
especially like seeing
him
underground
with with all with him and just getting
like all those um
getting getting like the chips kicked at
him
oh yeah well okay yeah so like there was
that uh essentially like a torture scene
poor vigilante had to endure some
partial partial well
yes but also like some and i'm gonna
read this right off the card here shock
and balls
[Applause]
[Music]
does that change your mind sorry pal not
for sale yeah what give it all you got
no no no no no
what was so funny about that was peace
make me like i'm not gonna tell you it's
not gonna make me and just him just not
having to deal with the pain of being
stubborn
but yes yep essentially he was kind of
like the balls were getting shocked yeah
he was like hey i'm not going to tell
you anything and the poor vigilante's
like please tell him please please i am
in so much pain yeah oh my god yeah and
then uh finally towards the end we do
realize that actually butterflies are in
fact butterflies too no one's shocked
and they are in the person's brain
feeding off of them
controlling them yeah it definitely felt
like a situation where like they were
controlling the body we don't really
know what
they are
but we get a glimpse of finally they are
in fact butterflies in a way we finally
get a glimpse of what maybe the
essence of the big situation of the
whole season is yeah the project
butterfly yeah and okay especially when
you see that there's a huge infestation
when it says potential butterflies and
it's just
yeah off the charts are huge and then
also and then let's not forget poor judo
master
getting the [ __ ] knocked out of him
uh
and is now
probably in the back of that truck
yeah
yeah and this poor guy i mean he was
beating everyone up yeah he was beating
everyone but he was not expecting that
yeah so
another thing i want to talk about
is that moment with you know harcourt
and peacemaker because you know
episode one we saw they got off to a
really uh on a really bad foot
episode two
she wasn't a big fan of them but they
actually connected in a big way knowing
that you know their both their fathers
kind of put them in the position of
being these killers very early on in
their in their lives so
i don't know you know i know i know it
seems like a mile away but
maybe maybe peacemaker's the one who can
get
hardcore to open up i mean i think i
felt like we could we can already tell
that they're probably gonna have enough
like their relationships probably gonna
get better or maybe it gets worse before
it gets better but you could see that
they're gonna have probably a bonding
and um
seeing it in episode three was just that
was it was like the the parental
issues that they're doing with which
honestly i feel like a lot of these
characters are dealing with parental
issues we've got like autobio 2 that's
dealing with her mom being amanda waller
yeah but going back to that heart heart
to heart with her heart harcourt
heart to heart with hardcore yeah
um we get to see like uh
you get you have that vulnerability
moment but i also love this kind of
romantic moment in a way where it was
like fireflies and the hair was blowing
and she was with the gun and she's
beautiful not like i was falling in love
with her
but essentially but essentially like
yeah i was i guess
you don't really know what
i guess you just don't really know how
peacemaker is feeling after that is it
romantic feelings is it just feelings of
understanding is it just friendship
feelings who knows but i mean i think
there's a lot of things there that could
probably put them together
and i think we're going to see that
relationship evolve eventually so yeah
that was our sort of recap yeah on this
episode but we have an amazing interview
happening
in just a little bit with danielle
brooks who plays adebayo so let's just
jump into it
[Music]
hello everyone joining me today we have
the wonderful and beautiful danielle
brooks you might realize if he isn't
here with me but i got this i can take
care of this so i'm gonna be chatting
with danielle brooks and just talking
and vibing about everything and anything
peacemaker let's get into it so danielle
without giving anything away what has
been like your favorite scene or
sequence to film so far in peacemaker
i feel like this like
don't give anything away but tell us
something i don't like
no i would say the first time you meet
this new black ops team and i don't
think that's giving anything away uh we
kind of like introduce all of the
characters in the space and and i feel
like i feel like that was the day like
james gunn kind of hazed me a little bit
because he
had me like improv
and i guess he was enjoying it so much
that he just kept making me do it over
and over and over
so the first big scene was kind of the
second one where you see her but um one
of the first
scenes that you will meet
at a bio and all of these characters um
i improv that whole thing
and i remember james just laughing over
and over where he couldn't even like he
was like now try this now try this but
every time you say he would be like
that
he couldn't get it out it was so much
fun but it was scary because
i was like
i felt like am i doing this right
because you have me keep doing this over
and over and i don't know
but uh he ended up using it and it and
so that that that made me feel good and
it was a fun day and and the cast were
so silly like um
it was just they were recording me it so
it's all this stuff but we had a good
time and so that's something i'll never
forget
yeah it just sound it just i i told this
to everyone but it looked like you guys
had so much fun just shooting this
show it seemed like there was a lot of
improv and comedy so i i feel like you
guys had the best time
we definitely had a good time shooting
this i mean
unfortunately we were doing it during
covet so we weren't able to spend like
personal time with each other but our
time on set was
more than enough to get to have a good
time and hang out
and um get to know each other you know
during this whole thing and then it's
definitely a boys club
myself and jennifer holland
were privy to uh but it was it was a lot
of fun and i had a good time cutting up
with them and and cracking jokes and
trying to keep up with their humor
uh-huh no it just everyone is hilarious
so it just seemed like you guys had the
best time but so how did it feel like
acting opposite of john cena it seems
like there was obviously these comedic
moments
but you also had to have those pretty
serious and vulnerable moments as well
how was all that
it was fun watching him work you know
he's very focused um but he's super
talented especially with the improv just
was really really talented
when it came when it comes to to the
improv and and of course the action like
i tried to take as m as much knowledge
from him on that and i and i think the
biggest thing i learned was like if you
don't have to do it then don't do it you
know it keeps very much like don't hurt
your knees if you don't have to hurt
your knees um so i i it was fun getting
to to learn from him too especially with
the action being it was so new for me
mm-hmm yeah so again let's let's talk
about that so the
coordination the the action parts you
you've never really done something like
that how was that experience for you
it was a blast and i really hope to do
more of it and not just do more of it
but really do more of it with james gunn
like i had such a good time like i was
really nervous at first learning guns
it just especially the period of time
we're in right now like i don't want to
touch it
but uh it was so empowering
to be able to at the end
be able to handle a gun
um with the care that you're supposed to
handle a gun with while looking like a
bad ass uh that was a lot of fun
and um just like
i i i did most of my stunts i had a
wonderful um
girl that did you know all of the things
for me um who's lovely
but i did most of them myself getting
harnessed in getting thrown across the
rooms and
all of that stuff so i had a i had a
great time and i would do it a hundred
times over for sure
girl you were doing you were handling
guns and doing your own stunt work
oh my gosh i would never i'd be so
scared oh my gosh give me more give me
more it was fun
girl you nailed that you nailed it so
there was this moment this mandela
effect moment
is it bernstein and or bernstein
stein
which one which one is the one that you
believe to be the truth
it is whatever adebayo said it is
because daniel don't know okay i don't
know i i'm gonna go with bernstein
because that's what my character
believes
and i think she's right
um but i really had no idea and when i
saw that on the page i was like what i
didn't even think about that like that's
crazy
uh there's so many other things like
that out in the world too
so in this episode goff was actually
pretty much torturing vigilante into
getting some information from him so i
kind of want to know what kind of
torture would make you talk the fastest
there's there's a lot of things that
could probably make me talk really fast
i mean
i was thinking like if you pull my nails
oh my god like if somebody tried to like
take my nails off just getting my nails
taken off from the nail salon
like the nail shop just doing that alone
is painful
and i would if somebody just did that
then you could definitely probably get
anything out of me
um
what about you i'm curious where would
yours be
uh
nails is pretty bad honestly any kind of
pain i'll probably be like i'm good
getting
yeah that's stupid getting a brazilian
you can like probably figure out a lot
about me
make it stop right yeah make it stop i
do not want to feel this again that's
why i go laser now oh don't do that
brazilian hurts
so
and then there's this amazing character
judo master so judo master is a really
fun character and i kind of want to know
danielle how would you
subdue judo master yourself
for me
i mean first of all can we talk about
how well he smashed vigilante
or
really
peacemaker with these
cheese cheeto things i was like oh my
gosh
that looks so painful you know that
machine that shoots the two balls at
people that looks painful
i think if i i would try to get him back
like that
um because i can't go as hard as what he
did to vigilante that is just like out
of this world
i can only imagine
how that possibly felt so i'm gonna go a
little lighthearted and a little bit of
torture
with the
the tennis balls being shot adam
oh that's a good one i also think it's
just so funny you're right like the
cheeto the cheeto flick that that looked
like it hurt it did
kudos to the sound of people in the
sound department because they made that
sound so terrible
so adebayo is an amazing character i
mean not only does she represent like
the queer community which i am part of
and it really means a lot to see that on
screen but also just her vault being
vulnerable having to be the daughter of
such a such a
a huge character in the dc universe i
mean i'd love to know how you feel about
her and how was it you know portraying
her at peacemaker
oh it was amazing i'm first of all glad
that you feel represented um you know i
very much have enjoyed every bit of this
and
um you know i think that's i know that's
why i signed on to it is because i have
not seen myself represented in this
space uh as a as a plus size girl so it
meant a lot to me when james gunn was
like i have something that i wrote for
you
um or have you in mind for that felt
really amazing so
um yeah to get to play at a bio that's
you know
lesbian
veterinarian
lost her job and now is put into this
team of
fighters
um she is now thrown into this world
that she has no clue how to navigate and
is faking it until she makes it
and um that's been a lot of fun because
that's pretty much what i've been doing
[Laughter]
you know but she becomes the audience's
perspective i think it's almost like
if you say to a regular person hey what
would it be like for you to jump into
this dc universe and
be working with peacemaker on this black
ops team how would you
handle it and basically that is who
leota is she is that person stepping
into this world that she
has no clue how to work through and um
but she does
have enough i guess street smarts to
handle herself and she has to prove
herself in this world
and uh we we see how she she navigates
that as we go along
yeah i mean just like you said i hey i
relate to the fake in it till you make
it okay that's what i live by
i get it i absolutely get it and like i
just like you said about leota she is a
very relatable character and i feel for
her and i i want her to succeed she's
like someone that i see myself as
whether she's a black she's lesbian
she's just like she's just like me and
it's like
it's really great to see that being
represented in peacemaker so it's really
i'm really happy that like you are happy
with how you portray her because you did
a phenomenal job thank you
thanks
and as a as a playing a lesbian my my
girlfriend's pretty hot isn't she
she is
yeah you guys did oh
an amazing job so it was really great to
see your like the relationships and the
interactions between honestly all the
characters mm-hmm yeah yeah for sure
all right well guys you know what time
it is it is our favorite segment eagly
mail
[Music]
so here's a question from one of our
community members in the dc community
if there was a chance for you to take a
prop costume or piece of the set home
without anyone noticing what would it be
um that's a really good question
i think
that i would
jack
um a piece from peacemaker's house he
had all of these really cool gnomes
like
a gnome smoking a joint or like all
these gnomes just like i don't they had
all these different personalities that
were not so typical
i was gone
i would take one up
you're absolutely right i was thinking
okay yeah you can go into peacemaker
grab like an awesome helmet or like an
awesome costume but no the gnomes were
pretty tight they are as the show goes
on too like there's some i would be on
set be like oh my gosh this is alcohol i
don't want this
but i didn't think to take it
or did you and we're not gonna yeah
[Laughter]
no your secret's safe with me you don't
you don't have it you don't have it you
didn't take it
[Laughter]
well danielle thank you so much for
joining me and answering all these
questions i've absolutely loved your
work um everywhere and especially on
peacemaker and thank you i can't wait
for everyone to see it seriously
thanks i can't either it was a fun show
and i hope that we get a season two
because
i had a blast right now we're gonna jump
back into the podcast and chat with our
our boy iffy so stay tuned all right we
might have gone to the best segment of
the podcast of this of this lovely show
which is the peace prize
[Music]
much like the eagley hug award and the
death to peace award we continue the
trend of the peace prizes great naming
convention on this episodes with the
butt baby award but baby yeah this is
the butt baby award its namesake is the
scene in which um
you know they're looking at the family
and the kid's ugly and he explains that
he it must be a butt baby and how he was
his all his like
his his older brother told him about
butt babies and he seems to have held on
to this
thing that an older brother might say to
you when you were younger and held it as
truth
and that's why i want to use the butt
baby award for for
things that he might say that are so
objectively wrong that they might be a
little bit right that's an attractive
couple that one looks like it came out
of them but the other one looks like a
fun baby a butt baby yeah my older
brother told me there's two types of
babies one that comes out of a woman's
vagina normal and then butt babies worst
in every way they come out of a woman's
butt you know sometimes you do look at
somebody you like you look so ugly you
might have come out of the butt yeah
sometimes you just look at someone and
you're like damn that guy came out of a
butt yeah so
yeah but yeah it really is like wild but
it is like such a perfect encapsulation
of who peacemaker is where he's getting
information
wrong or right and holding on to it for
dear life as if like this is like oh
it's fake until he make it yeah that's
literally that's that is the motto yeah
so congratulations to that scene yeah
congratulations to the first time of us
giving the butt baby award yeah yeah i
think i want that on a shirt
oh yeah yeah
oh my goodness
uh well you know thank you so much for
listening and watching uh we're gonna
have to get up out of here yet again but
make sure you subscribe don't forget to
follow us on twitter instagram and on
facebook and share all your favorite
moments for the show oh yeah and do you
want some peacemaker merch
i know i do well if you want to check
out the latest drop check out
shop.dcomics.com
yes yes
also get yourself a dc universe infinite
account so you have access to peacemaker
comics and more
also also
just don't forget to stream the show and
the podly episodes on hbo max so you can
be
super tat you know
super tapped in all right cool well you
know
that's all we have for you this week uh
see you around next episode
keep the peace